on y va ouais allez c'est parti
j'ai plutôt envie de vous faire
découvrir ce qui est à mon sens le coût
de la visite
se conduit peut radicalement changer
votre vie
quand on dit tendance conduite kwal
embrouillé avec se conduit sans
nucléaire qu'à se parlent et tétouan
canton descendance conduit madame
monsieur écoutez bien parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose mais c'est quoi
merde quand on descend dans ce conduit
vous n'allez pas me croire et pourtant
c'est la vérité
c'est juste dingue et alors c'est pas
tout
[Musique]
j'ai pas trouvé représenter le sujet en
fait tu sais toi moi ça m'angoisse pas
si toi
bon on a une raison d'être inquiet ça on
n'est pas là pour rien mais c'est pas
évident de d'en parler comme ça quoi
en fait on on a peur que vous ne preniez
pour des fous quoi c'est si on voudra
complices tout c'est ça
je tente quand même je me lance
[Musique]